have you found that the onion has been
subject to the same uh ridicule that you
guys have on social media or we're
subject to ridicule
oh you you tell me i mean i went to pull
up the babylon bee and it asked me if i
was uh going to a dangerous site so uh
did it really yeah we get a little bit
of that um you know
they have been um they've been targeted
with some criticism they do get fact
checked some the way that we've been
fact checked i think look it's it's you
see the same kind of bias at play here
with comedy that you see in every area
of life it's you know the the mainstream
media is really friendly to uh sources
that agree with them and i think you
know the onion
is
this is one of the topics we discussed
in our interview with elon musk he was
talking about the onion and how it's
it's further left than we are right it's
very politically correct very
politically correct you know they hit
all they had all the jokes from the
angle that you would expect them to hit
them from more so today than it wasn't
that way when it first started they were
a lot of speaking truth to power i mean
the whole concept of comedy for people
that don't know i mean if you're finding
yourself agreeing with the establishment
as a comedian you're a bad comedian you
know the the idea of speaking truth to
power people don't know who lenny bruce
is lenny bruce spent half of his career
in jail for refusing to to for just
cursing at that point yeah for lewd and
vicidious behavior talking in the 50s
yeah that was their culture at that
point but dude when i before i left new
york man i like you know i saw the tides
turning and i was like man this is not
about being funny this is about being on
message and then you saw people that
were getting you know fast-tracked
they're not going to name names you can
really easily google them remember who
they are their careers were getting fat
they were doing mics at the village
lantern and the next thing you know they
had netflix specials because they were
on message and was like this is they're
skipping 10 years here well now you got
people like chappelle who are
doing netflix specials and taking a lot
of heat for it because they step outside
the bounds of where there's what they're
supposed to be joking about right and i
think that's what comedians should be
doing i think they should be
making those jokes that nobody wants you
to make yeah um
no no but he's not but the highest form
of the art he's right though the highest
form of the art is saying things people
don't want to hear in a way they can't
stop listening well
you might have text that what what steve
harvey had to say was that you is that
you yeah yeah he basically saying
chappelle's the only person that can do
this any person out there other than
mice
speaking of himself he was talking about
dl
entertainer or kevin hart exactly i will
do one more special and that's when i'm
done because they're all reliant on
something harvey what's this point with
that steve because i'm gonna i'm gonna
let it fly and then i'm gonna go away
yeah he
despite all the success i've had despite
all the money despite all the power
despite all the fame i'm beholden to
sponsors exactly
subscription with netflix exactly so
netflix is probably going to go after
more companies look at tim dillon tim
dillon's the guy tim dillon is a guy
that no relation to seth no relation to
seth tim dillon you know rogan
in a certain way i mean marcelo opens
for him you make your you make yourself
uncancelable by insulating it but at the
end of the day it's the marketplace
you know if if 90 000 people are willing
to pay 4.99 a month for tim dillon and
all the sponsors can shove he can say
whatever he wants to say those people
are supporting him it's one of the ways
that we're independent is because we
have a subscription platform people can
subscribe to support us and so we don't
have to worry so much about um and this
is the reason we launched in the first
place is because we were worried we were
getting fact checked on facebook like
crazy they're rating our jokes false
they're giving our jokes a truth rating
yeah and then telling us jokes jokes
is they're supposed to be a little uh
have you ever gone they don't have a
truth rating they're funny or they're
not they're not true or false have you
ever gone down the rabbit hole with
who's fact checking you
cause that because i got demonetized on
facebook and i went down the rabbit hole
and was looking at who fact-checked me
and you end up looking at it it's like
some bot out in in in singapore that has
no
existence it's it's like this person and
it's just an opinion this person says
that you know what you're saying is
false i was like it's satire well we
found some of them so i'll give you an
example of one we did a story on how
ruth bader ginsburg had oh the ninth
circuit court had overturned the death
of ruth bader ginsburg that was the
headline right
and it's kind of a silly absurd headline
obviously you can't how do you overturn
somebody's death what does that even
mean obviously did they resurrect her
from the dead obviously it's a joke usa
today fact checked it rated it false and
if you scroll to the bottom of that fact
check it says it was paid for in part by
grants from facebook
so facebook
paid usa today to fact check our joke
and then send us a warning saying that
we made a joke that was false
so it's kind of a circular thing where
they're funding let me ask you pat talks
about
in the business planning workshop that's
where it really came to mind it talked
about finding an enemy finding an enemy
and that sort of motivates you to you
know double down on what you what you
want to accomplish and you know pat has
some enemies i'm sure he'll talk about
vocally do you have enemies that you say
all right i don't know if it's the onion
or if it's the establishment if it's
cancelled culture who's the babylon bee
enemy who do you go against
the enemy is anybody who's against free
speech the enemy is anybody who's trying
to censor you the enemy is anybody who's
trying to pressure you to censor
yourself so that you're not free to say
what you think and why you think it um
so you know anybody any comedian that
censors himself
in deference to the power that's trying
to get him to censor himself
is a joke himself i think and so
comedians should be pushing back on that
and making jokes humorous
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you